Speaker 1: I want to briefly look at an appearance
that radical, repugnant Republican Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor GREENE made at a religious
event.
I guess it's called Flashpoint Live.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE showed up with a big
cross necklace just to just to remind you
how deeply spiritual she is.
And she said defiantly, President Trump won
the state of Georgia.
This is a religious event, and it's just a
reminder of the inextricably linked Christian
dominionism, Christian nationalism and Trumpist
ideology, despite Trump personally not being
a religious guy.
Speaker 2: Okay, so, Marjorie, I told you
about some things I want to ask about, but
let's get right let's dove right into the
whole election integrity issue in Georgia.
Right.
What do these people need to do about that?
Speaker 4: Well, you know, that's a big issue
if you're so unsure how many people are from
Georgia.
I'm assuming everyone.
I love this, by the way.
Absolutely love it.
Okay.
So we all know that elections are, of course,
serious.
I mean, I don't know about you guys, but I
know that President Trump won in the.
Speaker 1: State of Georgia.
Standing ovation other than one guy walking
around with some kind of bucket.
Um.
Completely insane.
Completely unhinged.
And again, there is nothing in principal which
makes it so that if you're an evangelical
Christian, dominion is nationalist type.
You have to believe that the guy who lost
actually won.
Like you could just be a Christian dominionism
and be like, No, Trump lost.
But this movement has blended these two things
together in a very disturbing way.
Next clip, Marjorie Taylor GREENE says AOC
has the intelligence of less than a kindergartner.
Speaker 4: They want you driving electric
vehicles, ladies and.
Speaker 1: Gentlemen, very little.
Speaker 4: Worship the climate, and they very
much want to.
And this is the entire Democrat Party.
They want to pass the Green New Deal.
Speaker 1: Well, let me tell you.
Speaker 4: The problem with the Green New
Deal, other than the fact AOC, who has the
intelligence of less than a kindergartner,
by the way.
Speaker 1: That's a big applause line for
this group.
Speaker 4: It's true.
I work with her.
I now.
But anyways, the Green New Deal.
The problem with the Green New Deal, other
than the fact that it brings carbon down to
zero, which doesn't make sense because what
a trees and plants like.
Speaker 1: This is so stupid.
So she's like, listen, trees and plants like
carbon dioxide, the trees and the plants breathe
in the carbon dioxide and they spit out the
oxygen.
We burn in the oxygen, spit out the carbon
dioxide.
Now, this is stupid for.
It's probably stupid for ten different reasons.
But as I'm sure many of you know, the issue
is balance.
The issue is balance.
We have a planet.
We have a world, as Donald Trump likes to
say, and we need the oxygen and the CO2 to
be in balance.
The issue is we are overwhelming the planet
with CO2 more than the trees and the plants
can deal with.
Conversely, when when she talks about it,
listen, you get it.
We know it's very stupid.
She's throwing stones while in a glass house.
Then she calls the left godless.
And I love my state.
Speaker 4: I've lived here.
I was born here.
I grew up here just like many of you.
And there is no way that we are going to hand
over our home state of Georgia to the radical.
Speaker 1: What does that even mean?
Hand over the state.
I mean, Biden won.
That's what.
You can't really change that now.
Try as they might.
She.
Marjorie Taylor GREENE is still talking about
Brad Raffensperger, the secretary of state,
who, I mean, listen, for all of his faults,
refused to just flip the election because
Trump wanted it flipped.
Speaker 4: And then we have someone running
and this is where we're all going to have
a little trouble, because I'm still having
trouble.
We have another woman.
It's like a trifecta, everyone.
Another woman running for secretary of state
against Brad Raffensperger.
Right.
Well, you know, I supported Jody Hice.
Speaker 1: Jody Hice is an absolute lunatic
extremist who we've talked about before.
So still talking about Brad Raffensperger.
GREENE warns that Stacey Abrams is a major
threat coming in November.
She's the Democratic gubernatorial nominee.
I would love for Stacey Abrams to be the next
governor of Georgia.
Speaker 4: We have a major threat coming in
November.
And I'm going to say there's three of them.
And I don't think there's enough people talking
about this.
Right.
One of them is named Stacey Abrams.
Exactly.
Exactly right.
Speaker 1: And you know what?
She's actually right.
There is a threat coming from Stacey Abrams
in the sense that she threatens to overturn
Republican rule in Georgia.
And it would be delightful.
Really important race to get involved in if
you're thinking, well, do I want to get involved
in Oz versus Fetterman in Pennsylvania, that's
a good one.
Do I want there's lots of important races
that could make a difference.
Georgia having a Democratic governor could
be a huge deal in 2024.
We'll have these clips on our Instagram, which
you can find at David Pakman show.
Back right after this.